today we reached a new important
milestone
the eu japan green alliance it is our
commitment
to be a leader in climate neutrality by
2050
and its ambitious alliance will boost
cooperation
in many areas energy transition business
regulatory cooperation innovation
environmental protection or sustainable
finance
we also discussed the digital
transformation of our societies
the eu wants to make the next 10 years
our digital decade we will work with
japan
on emerging technologies critical
materials 5g
6g artificial intelligence data and
platforms
and this will boost the competitiveness
of both the eu and japan and set
standards
in multilateral flora we also discussed
this morning
our bilateral relations the full
implementation
of our economic partnership agreement to
boost bilateral trade investment
should remain our joint priority
japan is the eu's first connectivity
partner
and must continue to make concrete
progress on high standard
infrastructure projects in third
countries we should complete
our negotiations of the so-called
horizontal
agreement on air transport as soon as
possible
and we are fostering cooperation in the
industrial research and innovation
and space sectors and this includes the
possibility for japan
to be associated with the horizon europe
research program
we've also strengthened our security
and defense cooperation the eu
decided to reinforce its strategic focus
on the indo-pacific region we have a
strong interest
to intensify with japan our cooperation
in maritime security technology
cooperation
cyber security disinformation and to
promote
fundamental values and principles in the
region
as human rights and democracy are
attacked around the world
the eu and japan need to coordinate
our actions we also discussed a range of
regional affairs
including the situation in the east and
south china sea
dprk iran and gcpoe
myanmar ukraine russia or china
we look forward to our next meeting in
tokyo to further strengthen
our eu japan relationship i thank you
thank you mr president and now i pass
the flow to the president of the
european commission thank you very much
good morning
indeed we had a very productive eu
japan summit japan is
a like-minded partner of the european
union and we have made
good progress on our partnership there
is still a lot to be done
but we went through each of the topics
and there's a lot of cooperation that we
are working on to increase
the the common agenda indeed the first
point on our common agenda was climate
the
the fight against climate change and
here
japan is one of the first countries that
has committed
to climate neutrality in 2050 it was
last fall
so they are like the european union very
committed
to the long-term goals i very much
welcome that
it will be interesting to see the goal
defined by japan by 2030
and we want to work very uh much we want
to work
much closer on this topic together
that's why we indeed started the first
ever
green alliance with japan and there's a
whole agenda that is in this green agile
alliance um in the green transition
we want to inspire others to join of
course and therefore this clean alliance
is also so important in the run up
to the cup 15 on biodiversity in kunming
and the cup 26 on climate in glasgow
because we
really need to move to to form this
movement
towards tangible reliable goals
we put for ourselves out there to fight
climate change
and to fight the loss of biodiversity
there are few topics or examples of the
green alliance
for example that we shape global
standards or that we
both push forward sustainable finance
like green bonds
and that we are firm on carbon pricing
but we also see
an enormous potential in cooperating in
the green alliance
for example on clean energy we will be
signing a memorandum of cooperation
on hydrogen with japan in the second
half of these years
this paves the way but
there are also other topics like the
offshore wind
to work there closely together all this
was part of our
of our discussions in this summit
on bilateral trade another topic here
the cornerstone is the economic
partnership agreement
it has joined priority and we have to
implement it fully
we will focus on delivering concrete
benefits
in non-tariff areas and on clarifying
the free flow of data under our
agreement for instance
and uh we will continue working on
market
access within this economic partnership
agreement
for eu agricultural products and on the
remaining sanitary and phyto-sanitary
issues
that have to be resolved on multilateral
trade
we share absolutely the views on the
necessity to reform wto
and as we're very happy that the
u.s with president biden is back at the
negotiation table
we should now use the momentum mainly to
develop new multilateral rules
and to unlock the dispute settlement
mechanism
here we agreed that we will push
together
for really having a concrete result in
the ministerial conference
of wto in the second half of the year
on digital japan is our oldest and
closest partner
in the digital field and once more
here too we share the same vision
of human-centric digitization
so we want to build a partnership for
the digital decade with japan
we are investing in connectivity
we can work together on standards for
example
on the ethical use of artificial
intelligence
we will promote as i've said the digital
trade flows through resilient supply
chains and secure
cyberspace just to name a few examples
of this potential
and fifth on my last point
we also discussed the global fight
against the pandemic
both the european union and japan have
made significant contributions
to covax to ensure access to vaccines
for all
the european union will continue to
support the efforts to fight the
pandemic
including exporting vaccines
here there was a very clear question
from our japanese partners
it is a sign of solidarity and a sign of
friendship with japan
that so far the european union has
authorized
more than 100 million doses to be
exported
to japan that is approximately enough to
vaccinate
40 percent of the population and this
reflects
the very strong bonds between the
european union and japan thanks a lot
thank you madam president let me simply
highlight um
that the eu japan green alliance and the
ambitious
joint statement on eu and japan was
published
just now on our website and we're going
to turn to the q
a session now please can i ask you to um
to put your cameras on and raise your
yellow hand it is now
just minding you that we have japanese
translation as well and we have the
first question from associated press by
samuel
petrikin samuel you have the floor
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yes little to act uh i think
indeed we have of course said that we're
looking forward to the olympic games
no more has been discussed but uh the
signal that
from the european union uh 100 more than
100 million doses of vaccines have been
authorized to be exported to japan
also is a strong sign that we support
any preparation for the olympic games
games and the safety
of these games thank you
turning to stuart lau now from politico
stewart um hi
thank you i'd just like to ask more
specifically about
the issues of the east china sea and the
south china sea that you discussed with
the japanese side because
um would like to know more about what
exactly was discussed
and second of all i mean on taiwan the
japanese prime minister when he was in
washington
they shat light on the issue of taiwan
did the issue come up at all
during today's um summit thank you
yes indeed the maritime security is a
top priority and
and we think with japan we are convinced
with japan
this is very important to cooperate you
know to make sure that we can improve
the maritime security uh everywhere but
also in this part in the world which is
very important
for the international trade but it's
just also the possibility to
to strengthen the cooperation and very
concrete for example
we organized in djibouti common
exercises
japan with european member states
and we we announced today to the
japanese prime minister
that we are ready the european union
with our member states
to strengthen the european presence in
order to play our role to assume
also our part of responsibility in order
to guarantee
as much as possible the maritime
security which is a very
important topic and indeed in taiwan
um the prime minister had also the
opportunity to to explain
uh the the vision uh and you know that
uh
we we share and we support uh his
vision on discretion
next question is for david carretta
radio radically david
mercier
if i can come back to the issue of
olympics game and vaccines
until now japan has inoculated
10 million of doses
2 percent of the population
even if it received the 100 million
doses
i'm wondering if you have discussed this
with the prime minister
of the country and if you think that
it's
a problem not just for the olympics game
and the safety on all participants
but also in terms of justice
in the sense in the sense that
the doses that are not used by japan
cannot use
can cannot be used by other countries
thank you very much for the opportunity
to ask my question
yes should i please yeah
so the 100 million doses of vaccines
have been
authorized for export by the european
union
but we do not have knowledge about
delivery schedules
this has to be clearly differentiated
the one
or the other and the second point is
when you were speaking about
fairness and solidarity that is the
reason why
last week in the g20 global health
summit
it was a major step forward that
the our industrial partners by
integrafizer moderna
and johnson johnson committed publicly
in this
global health summit to deliver 1.3
billion doses of vaccine this year
to low and middle-income countries for
low-income countries
non-profit and middle-income countries
at lower costs
so there are very clear commitments here
too
and it is important to have a uh to have
this put this in proportion
thank you madam president thank you mr
president and this concludes our press
conference for today may i please
point out the publication on our
websites
and thank you to the japanese press for
following this press conference
see you soon
[Music]
you